have you seen this celeb jets
twitter account that tracks celebrities
private jets no and where they go oh
twitter account sorry yeah yeah i
thought you said tick tock account oh
sorry it was a tick tock video about the
account that i saw i [ __ ] hate that i
was like i hate the internet so much
dude i said i hate the internet so much
why you see that tick tock about that
twitter account that was like tracking
stuff like on youtube yeah yeah i mean
oh my god we do the same [ __ ]
no it i know it just i hate that the
internet is so like like this like
it makes things sound deep when it's not
if you just oh yeah i saw this thing on
youtube right right okay but like
everything gets screen recorded and you
know re-uploaded everywhere it just
pisses me off
anyways celeb just so anyways he's
talking about kylie jenner's jet if you
search celeb jets kylie
maybe on twitter or on google try and
find like a compilation or something
but like she'll just regularly fly
across la
to be traffic
it's [ __ ] up bro
from where i don't know if it's for sure
like
like i don't know if they're just moving
the jet
to another place to get gas or something
like that if they have to register it
like i don't know if she's actually on
the jet
but like it's like three times a week
she'll just go from van nuys to
where
camarillo
no three minutes it's three minutes
but
doesn't she live in like calabasas
she's just
like i don't you still have to drive
maybe she's going to like ohio or
something i don't know that is [ __ ]
wild
van nuys is like in the [ __ ] deep
they must be talking about the
is there a private jet airport in van
nuys yeah that's how broke we are we
yeah there is you've been there
uh all the time
whenever my dad flies his cessna cessna
yeah
um
damn
and uh it's like make sure you guys keep
buying her tequila guys get uh jet plane
fuels experience it's kind of funny
because the dude that was you know
screen recording it and like filming
himself was basically like don't ever
talk to me about like if a celebrity
talks to you a celebrity at this
you know scale talks to you about the
environment yeah
just [ __ ] shut up because yeah
like you're the the amount of damage
you're doing to the environment just
with a three minute flight is yep is 10
years worth of plastic straws it's
hilarious that they just don't
care
yeah either they
yeah the environment's [ __ ] up or
whatever yeah not that you know i mean
if i was balling like that that's what
i'm saying if somebody
sat you down and was like listen
we could sit right now we got to go to
oxnard
we could sit on the 101 for an hour and
a
half
or we could take this three-minute
flight
it's like some turtles might die
i mean yeah i'm
taking that flight right i'm sitting in
traffic
doing my civic duty
yeah okay now if a moose would die
you could hit the moose on the 101.
most of the plane that's what i'm
envisioning
you think a helicopter no i'm thinking
it turns into a helicopter with a spin
oh yeah or it just goes through the jet
and just missed
that's what i would do
that's what it would be
yeah this is the video
i mean it's not it's nothing
you find that boost video we have some
people pretty mad at us really
yo trigger warning a little bit
like once was cool but 17 times in a row
there's no trigger warning on twitter
it's true you scroll down that [ __ ] just
starts playing yeah
that's way that's way worse than what
we're doing yeah
yeah we we say hey you see the video of
that mustang
yeah if you hear us say that just scrub
forward yeah you can't be mad at us you
can't be mad at me
if you hear us say that just skip the
episode because we're gonna watch the
video over and over for the rest of the
hour yeah
did you see last team joseph nah i was
like one of those moose dying ones
i was gonna laugh too hard and i was at
work so i had to turn it off
that's why engagement goes down because
people are going to be too distracted
from what they're doing
[Laughter]
yeah that's one of the most dying
episodes oh the one where they play the
same six second clip for an hour
straight yeah i watch every other
episode of the tmg podcast
oh
you'll run that back
so uh look at the way that run that back
i got a hilarious rant look running back
i got a hilarious message off that some
dude was like i know you think you're
the car guy in the group but it wasn't a
renault clio and he corrected me on the
model i was dying
no he's just being funny okay yeah
this is so funny because i don't think
you're the car guy in the group it
wasn't a renault clio dude it was a
hyundai gets
oh is this this is 4k all right
wow this is another
really funny video
america's funniest home mooses if you
don't want to see a moose die skip the
last 15 minutes of the oh
oh yeah that's that's the classic one
yeah damn
it's a good subreddit why were they
filming
go to that let's watch them yo dawg the
[ __ ] the
the heat map on the on the replay no no
look at that real quick look at that
[ __ ] look at that
look i've not seen a youtube video with
that much volume on the heat map
that's how you know this it is
it'd be so funny if it spiked like all
the way to the top dude no it's just
like a yeah
where the moose went it's just a brick
yeah yeah like all the way up until they
hit and then just sharp
let it go one more time yeah oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
really tame reaction leading into it oh
my god oh my god oh my god
you know you know the pieces of [ __ ] we
were we were filming that would be like
yeah
oh no oh no
not like this guy yeah this guy's like
oh [ __ ] oh
yeah for a sec
dude with a small mouth right there
all the moves
oh the [ __ ]
moose yo yo sir moles
oh my moose just got dead
damn
oh my god oh my god
oh my god i got this
connie stay there i'm gonna go check on
the booth
yo whoever uploaded this i've always
thought that looks like elon no
i've always thought whoever uploaded
this doesn't care because why would they
put the [ __ ] slow-mo
like it's crazy to go to premiere and be
like
all right yo copy paste
25 percent speed
go back to the heat map he kicked it but
i wish it increased again right before
the slo-mo yeah
he kick flipped
that one's that one lived though yeah
oh
damn
you